Let's go back to slide so I can make a quick comment.
Okay.
the issue with the issue with
e to the power x
is that when you derive it?
You get e to the power x again?
now when we take the derivative of you e to
the power x we're not trying to
derive e to the power of X that
term specifically rather we are
trying to derive.
the thing
to which your VX is equivalent?
That is the McLaren series.
Okay, so we use e to the power x
to represent the McLaren Series so we don't have to write down
the whole.
Series every time we want to talk about it. We just
use it's about X, but the problem is when you
take its derivative.
You can eat the power x so in a way the T.
in a way that t
is going to help us express.
the series The Way We want to
and then
Evaluate the terms within that series accordingly.
So T is really nothing more than are helping variable. It's
just facilitates.
deriving
the terms of that sequence
determine that series and we will look at that in a second.
So what happens when you raise or what happens when you take
the derivative of e to the power x?
Times t e raise the power exam see what happens.
Is that by the power rule?
The second variable has to come down.
And he gets to keep its powers.
So we you take the derivative of e to
the power x times T. You can x times e to
the power T times x
and that's what we want.
That's what we want. This is going to help us evaluate the moments.
of the random variable
So that's that's the only reason we have tea in there.
It's the same reason why algebra, for example, you would use parentheses.
In an expression why you would sometimes
move numbers around?
or factor them
you're not changing the quantity. You're not changing
the value.
of the
expressions of the equation you just expressing when
a different way so you can solve
so I can solve the equation solve for x that's what algebra is
about. And this is what we do and we do the same thing here.
So that's it. That's what he is. It's a helper valuable. It's
a variable to help you with your mathematical rotation.
Okay, so now let's go back to these. Let's go
back to the reader now.
now if we did not have
t
as an extra variable.
In the power of E.
Then we will not be able to.
Derive the terms in this sequence any further because
we know we know what happens when you have it raised the
power x you derive it you get EU to the power x again.
And this is where you see T help us.
In fact, that's why it's sometimes referred to as the
help of a variable.
Okay, so now let's take
what we have now understood about
You know.
e to the power x times t
populate those values populate the the values
for T and X.
to see what
you know the sequence evaluates to
okay, so we have the moment generally function which is equal to
this.
Well sequence.
and then when we take and then of course when we
right out the sequence.
And then we take the derivative.
of each
term within the sequence as you can see here.
If e raised to the power x sub y sub T
then we take when we take the derivative of the first.
Term, okay.
By the power rule x sub I comes down.
Here is x sub 1 x sub 1 comes down.
and of course
he gets to keep its powers and then multiplied by
its probability.
Then X up two comes down.
then x sub 3 comes down all on
and on until we have
You know all of the all of the X's.
multiplied with a corresponding probability
so plugging in the numbers we get, you know zero time.
the first random the first
value in the random value is zero. It's probably 0.1.
Okay, let's look at the table very quickly.
0 has probabilities 0.1.
1 has probably 0.2. So if you
scroll back down.
If you scroll back down.
If you scroll back down there you have it.
multiply the multiply the
so multiply the X the small x
with this probability distribution.
And you keep going and now and on and on I'll tell you all of
the axis and they're probably distributions.
And that's how you get.
the first moment
the expected value
Okay.
Knowing this it will make it easy for you to find the
remaining moments moment. 2 1 3 1.4. Let's quickly
look at those.
So to calculate the second moment.
Calculating the second moment is the variance and
of course once you have the values you can get the standard deviation for
the random variable.
So what you do?
The variance is indicated as Sigma squared
standard deviation as Sigma. If you take
the square root of if you take the square root of the
variance, it gets standard deviation. But anyway.
That is to say that you are taking the expected value.
for the
second moment
So the calculate that to calculate the variance.
You take the expected value of x
minus.
it's mean
r squared
so two things to talk about here. First of all,
how do we arrive at the mean?
Because we calculate the force moment, but calculating the
first moment now, why do we Square it now? The reason
we Square the variance?
is because we want to
deal with negative numbers
if you have a positive number and a negative number potentially
can cancel them out.
by squaring negative numbers
All of the numbers become positive if they're negative, they're positive
and they're positive they remain positive.
Then we add them all up.
And we get the variance.
So we will.
Square it to deal with the minuses. So all
the numbers are positive and it would score and then
we take the square root to bring it to make it proportional again.
And that's what this is talking about. Is that is what this this line
is talking about.
and of course
if you look at this document, you will see that it's
almost self-explanatory
now the third moment.
has to do with skewness, so we wanted to be
centered
or if you want to be compared to the mean average we wanted
to be relative to zero, okay?
so we need
we need we need to take into
consideration.
the signs
of the integers that we adding up so minus is a pluses.
matter
now
when we get this skewness.
we want to
we want to have a
we we want to measurement to be independent of
any particular measuring unit. So inches centimeters, what
have you so we divided by Sigma cubed.
now similarly for the
kurtosis
we have the same.
term
x minus mu raised to
the power of 4 all divided by.
Sigma raised to the power 4
and this will give us the kurtosis.
now
for
this
now for this time
knowing this much about the moments is sufficient. If
you want to get into further detail about you know,
why we raise the power 4 and looking at
proofs and we can leave that for another time.
But it's for for now. This is
sufficient. Okay, especially the first and second moments.
Knowing them in more detail.
Will be more helpful for us.
because first of all, we understand the concept
of
the moment and calculate the moment and it will
help us appreciate.
You know the formula for the second third
and fourth moments.
Now, of course, we'll be dealing with moments.
for
Our statistical studies in R. Now
we want compute these.
Like we will not have to actually calculate them using.
Sequences and moment generating functions
and R because these formulas are
built into our studio.
So we can quickly evaluate the value by invoking a
function.
and
and that's all there is to it.
Okay.
So you can refer to this document.
If you want to you know understand.
a moments and moment generating functions